pour frédéric vous êtes béarnais ex
publicitaire et romancier doux interview
mensonges et rebelles qui vous pousse à
pousser un bougé par un génial non je
suis la rebelle je suis la récalcitrante
voir l'insurgé vous êtes ultra libéral
sur le plan politique le très proche de
la madelin us d'alain minc en fait oui
vous vous trouvez pas que ce système
ultra libéral est porteur de violence
sociale
non pas du tout vous voulez rire ah bon
le marché s'autorégule bon il ya des
licenciements massifs
quand on fait des bénéfices mais c'est
très bien c'est pour la santé des
entreprises
oui beaucoup d'entre eux sont rentrés je
lui fais des bénéfices doit licencier
des gens en prévision du jour n ont pas
plu évidemment sinon leurs actionnaires
comment ils vivent
il faut je crois que c'est très
important que que les financiers
puissent s'engraisser un petit peu sur
le dos de des ouvriers non fachos 500
frédérick haas vous partager la vie de
jacques séguéla qui pensent que la pub
est là pour apporter du rêve et du
bonheur aux gens
oui d'abord je rédigerai saluer
l'artiste parce que jacques séguéla
c'est un artiste c'est un poète des
temps modernes et je pense que la
publicité à la porte pas seulement du
bonheur elle elle est sincère quoi ouais
comme moi en ce moment
oui bien sûr que la vie n'est compris le
principe que séguéla soit un artiste je
suis d'accord d'accord
alors y avait une chambre en pas
frédéric avec vous là votre limousine
avec les vitres fumées ses assistants
qui sont toujours là pour vous allumer
des cigarettes c'est vous ça vraiment
oui parce que je pense que le pognon
c'est bien moi je trouve que je vis pour
ça et j'ai envie de voila j'ai envie
d'avoir une une existence coupé du monde
coupé de la réalité est évidemment bien
sûr ça va de soi ouais
et pourquoi avoir laissé tomber
l'ecstasy pour la cocaïne saintrick
jamais compris chez vous ça ah non moi
en fait j'ai jamais pris ni l'un ni
l'autre
ah ouais ah non moi ça m'intéresse pas
je trouve que la drogue c'est pas bien
ça veut dire c'est c'est dangereux quoi
il faut vous jamais en prendre même un
pétard j'ai jamais fumé un pétard de ma
vie ouais
quelle est la partie de votre corps que
vous préférez fred avec ma [ __ ]
cliquez là on se connaît bien mais il ya
un truc qui m'a toujours surpris chez
vous c'est cette incapacité à tromper la
mère de votre enfant même dans les
situations les plus propices aux vices
finalement comment vous faites interview
mensonge là-dessus lalalalalala voulait
vraiment coincé
non eh bien eh bien oui je la trouve
tout le temps je la trouve tout le temps
j'adore ça je pense qu'il faut se faire
sucer il faut il faut déjà que faciale
tous les soirs
c'est un bout chez vous les oreilles
mahdi lesjak faciale ou fait 80 pages là
dessus sur comment s'essayer comment
remercier la bienséance dans les zac
social alors on à la baronne vous
préférez bien entendu prédéry kadhafi du
manège près serbe à six actuellement je
sais pas je me sentirais plus à l'aise
avec vous c'est vrai ma femme qu'on va
solder tous les crédits
sinon vous plaisez à madame de fontenay
madame de retirer son nom parce qu'il ya
un truc qui se passe c'est marrant il
fut aux nobles c'est un peu lolita à
l'envers bon frédéric alors comment
expliquer ce dégoût des boîtes
échangistes ebooks vais tester ça je
trouve sa source a en tout ces gens qui
qui qui veulent se met nu devant
d'autres personnes s'entassent et comme
ça me dégoûte
ça me dégoûte je trouve que tu as sont
globalement le sexe me dégoûte voilà ça
intéressant à jouer et les vacances en
thaïlande gérer uniquement pour écrire
vous seulement alors c'est vrai ouais
budget de développement économique du
pays enfin votre double discours prêt
très social
mais c'est pour écrire oui oui et aussi
manger démangeait des nems cette
recherche de saint-ex devant vous ça
vient d'où
ça vient d'eux
du pape je crois que le pape c'est un
mec super il va être content mais c'est
l'interview mensonges dans qu'il est
perturbé est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec des visuels quand tu dis beigbeder
c'est un mec bien
oui oui mais il pas le seul à le dire
joue légal dalaï lama ya nelson mandela
seulement deux mais il a dit si
l'humanité était composé de beigbeder le
monde serait meilleur
annoncé par vaclav havel qui a dit ça
aussi je dînais avec kofi annan et
boutros boutros ghali et ils me disent
frédéric ce que vous faites pour pour
l'humanité nous fait chier à l'est de
bonheur et moi je
il
bienvenue